Youngblood is continuing to use his
voice to support the lgbtq+ community in
a recent online Q&A the British singer
discussed everything from the number of
tattoos he has to his favorite dessert
but it was his words of wisdom for the
lgbtq+ community and fans suffering from
mental health issues that really made an
impact I think the best advice to fight
anxiety and paranoia is to kind of
because I suffer from both I think the
thing about it as soon as I kind of ride
the wave and embrace that I've got it
and it's happening to me it can't get my
breath back it will come and then
surround yourself with people who
understand it and everything will be
alright just take a deep breath ride the
wave know what you're going through
and just it will it will pass over your
promise sure the singer has often been
vocal about his own struggles with
stress and anxiety so he had no problem
giving his advice on how to deal with
them and when he was asked to give his
best advice for lgbtq+ fans he said
every single person on this planet has
the right to love whoever they want and
should be loved in return by whoever
they choose that's it . period anybody
who doesn't like that is just completely
delusional sending all my love to
everyone love you rock love that message
when we caught up with Youngblood during
a stuff on his twisted tales of Ritalin
Club tour in Toronto he opened up about
his approach to sexuality and gender and
remaining true to himself I just
wanna be fluid in every aspect of my
life and just wear what makes me feel
comfortable or do what makes me feel
comfortable
I love whoever makes me feel comfortable
or look like whatever I want to look
like putting on a mask is over
authenticity is your biggest superpower
to be originally yourself is your
biggest superpower you are allowed to be
to look like to feel to love to have sex
to do your hair in any way that you
identify in any way that you see fit and
that's what's cool now social media
isn't the only place where he's giving
his honest unfiltered look at these
issues he just released a new track
about self-acceptance called original me
which features imagine dragons frontman
Dan Reynolds who has also been a strong
ally and activist for the lgbtq+
community
[Music]
I just won out I pick up the phone and
he's just like y'all I love everything
you stand for because he's such a
massive activist in terms of being
yourself and with the lgbtq+ community
like he's such an advocate for making
people feel good and making people feel
wanted and accepted and for his upcoming
EP underrated youth it's all about
telling stories straight from his heart
they see peas kind of me talking from
the hall as I said earlier like the
first record was about my head and walk
thought but this EP is more emotional
because the stories I've heard man and
the people of Matt what do you think
about young bloods online qat do you
relate to a celebrity more if they're
open about their own struggles do you
think Youngblood is a great ally for the
lgbtq+ community let us know in the
comments below and don't forget to
subscribe to ET Canada's YouTube
[Music]
you
[Music]